[موسيقى]
تفرض الحرب في اوكرانيا
الجديده فما استمرار الوصول الشحنات
الاسلحه الغربيه الى كيف بدات روسيا في
استخدام اسلحه حديثه ومتطوره وادخالها
لقوتها الناريه في ساحه الحرب لاول مره
تقرير لوزاره الدفاع البريطانيه اكد ان
روسيا استخدم الطائرات سوخوي 57 المتطوره
لاطلاق الصواريخ بعيده الماده من الاجواء
الروسيه على اهداف اوكرانيا
لكن بما تتميزو هذه المقاتله هي من الجيل
الخامس لطائرات الاسرع من الصوت ثنائيه
المحرك دخلت الخدمه لاول مره عام 2020 في
القوات الجو الفضائيه الروسيه تستخدمها
روسيا في تدمير شبكه الدفاع الجوي في
اوكرانيا لقب غنيت بثمن اي المجرم
لامكانياتها في تنفيذها هامه متعدده
اكتشاف الاهداف على ماذا اكثر من 400 كلم
قادره على تتبع الستين هدفا في ان واحد
في خطوه تتخذها موسكو للرد على التسليح
الغربي لاوكرانيا ابرزه خطط دعمها بمنظومه
الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه
نشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لقطات المظهر
استخدام المقاتل الصخري 57 صاروخ كروز
الموجه تلفزيونيه ضد اهداف العسكريه في
كيف وتدميرها
اقتراب دخول الحرب في اوكرانيا عامها
الثاني تسعه اوكرانيا لتقويه دفاعاتها
وترسمتها العسكريه للحفاظ على اراضيها
والحد من التقدم الروسي
الغرب بمواصله الحرب وضغط اسلحه جديده
ويقول ان جلها يفوق التوقعات